we're on problem 67 they asked us how
many terms is the binomial expansion of
x squared plus 2 y to the third to the
20th power contained and so right when
you seed oh my god to the 20th power you
might say oh that that'll take me
forever to do and then I'll have to
count the terms but ever they're just
asking you how many terms they're not
asking you to find the expansion so you
just have say oh boy let me just think
about this a little bit and just think
of it this way hey X plus y X plus y to
the first power has how many terms it
has well it's just X plus y right it's
just X plus y and so it has two terms X
plus y squared that is equal to x
squared plus 2xy plus y squared so that
has three terms if I were to do X plus y
to the third power I could do a binomial
expansion I can do it with Pascal's
triangle let me do it Pascal's triangle
I have the 1 and the one that's to the
first power and the second power those
are the coefficients then the third
power the coefficients become 1/3 cuz 1
plus 2 is 3 3 1 and actually I don't
even have to expand it out I'll do it
just for a little practice it's X to the
3rd plus 3x squared y plus 3x y squared
plus y to the 3rd I just use these but
any when you take any binomial and you
take it to the 3rd power you end up with
four terms all right and depending on
how you think of it if you think of it
with Pascal's triangle every time we go
down we're just going to be adding
another term right when we take the
fourth power it's gonna have five terms
or when you think about just the when we
use the binomial expansion and you might
want to watch some videos on that there
you also have if you're taking it to the
nth power you end up with n plus 1 terms
so in this example we have a binomial
final just means a two-term polynomial
and we're hanging to the 20th power if
we're taking to the 3rd power we'd have
four terms we're getting to the fourth
power we'd have five terms so we're
native to the 20th power we're gonna
have twenty-one terms and that's choice
B next problem
next problem all right they want us to
keep doing these and we'll do it because
they want us to alright what are the
first four terms in the expansion of 1
plus 2x to the 6th power and here we'll
just use the binomial expansion because
I think that's what they want us to do
and that's probably the fastest way to
do it so let's just think of the
coefficients first so this is going to
be well let's just do it this is going
to be equal to 6 choose 0 and we're just
going to do the first four terms times 1
to the sixth times 2x to the 0 so I
don't have to write that plus 6 choose 1
and actually we'll probably just have to
figure out the third term because that's
the only time where they start to change
6 choose 1 times 1 to the fifth right 1
to the fifth power times 2 x to the
first power times 2x plus 6 choose 2
times I mean these ones we you know it
doesn't matter what power isn't 1 to the
4th times 2x squared plus let's say they
want the first 4 so let's do this last
one 6 choose 3 times 1 to the fifth
times sorry 1 to the third you have to
decrement the one every time times 2x to
the 3rd all right and if we look at the
choices just to save time if we look at
the choices okay we agree that the first
term is going to be 1 so that we can
definitely say it's going to be 1
because all the choices are 1 the second
term is definitely going to be 12x and
then we start getting some disagreement
on the third term so let's see what the
third term 6 choose 2 that's equal to 6
factorial over 2 factorial over 6 minus
2 factorial let me scroll down a little
bit so that is equal to 6 factorial or
which is 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 but the 1 doesn't do a change
anything divided by 2 factor which is 2
times 1 or just 2 divided by 6 minus 2
factorial that's 4 factorial so times 4
times 3
times two times one that cancels out
with that the two and the six cancel out
and you get three so you end up with
three times five so you end up so the
six choose two becomes 15 right three
times five that's 15 times one to the
fourth which is one times two x squared
so times 4x squared and so that's 15
times four that's 60 x squared so the
third term is going to have is going to
be 60 x squared and we're done
this is choice D is the only one that
has 60 x squared as the third term so
we're done we didn't even have to go to
the fourth term so if we by carefully
looking at the choices we actually only
have to evaluate one of the terms next
problem let's see all right problem 69
they say let me let me copy and paste it
what is the sum of the infinite
geometric series 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8
all the way over there I'll be frank
well I do now remember the formula but a
lot of times in life you might forget
the formula and there's a trick to
reproving the formula for yourself just
in case you forget it when you're when
you're 32 years old like me so let's say
that I I'm trying to find the infinite
sum of a geometric series so let's say
that the sum and I'm gonna reprove it
right here in the midst of this test and
I've done this in the midst of tests and
it saved me so it's nice to know the
proof and it actually impresses people
if you know people who are impressed by
proofs so let's say the sum is equal to
a to the 0 a to the 0 well actually
let's say let's see this is interesting
because they're starting at 1/2 actually
let's just do the concrete number so we
want to figure out this exact sum so
let's say that the sum is equal to 1/2
to the 1 plus 1/2 squared plus 1/2 to
the third it's the whole one-half to the
third right plus and you just keep going
right fair enough now let's take
one-half times the sum so one-half times
the sum what is this equal to well if I
took one-half times this whole thing now
one half I would have to distribute it
over each of these terms so one-half
times this term times this first term
1/2 times 1/2 to the first well that's
not going to be 1/2 squared right 1/2
squared right all I did is I I'm
distributing this 1/2 times each s or
1/2 times 1/2 to the first that's 1 x
squared now 1/2 times 1/2 squared well
that's going to be 1/2 to the third
power right and just keeps going you're
just gonna keep it's an infinite series
right so let me ask you something if I
subtracted this from that what do I get
let's see what I get so I get s minus
1/2 s right I'm subtracting that from
that is equal to this minus this well if
I'm subtracting the green stuff from the
yellow stuff this is gonna cancel out
with that that's going to cancel out
with that and I'm gonna be left with is
this
first thing right here all right that's
the trick and you could prove it
generally for any base and I thought it
was interesting because a lot of times
they start with the zeroth power and
this isn't this problem was interesting
because they start with 1/2 to the first
power but anyway let's figure this s
minus 1/2 s well that's just 1/2 s 1/2 s
is equal to 1/2 and then you have s is
divide both sides by 1/2 or multiply
both sides by 2 and you get s is equal
to 1 now a lot of you may you know there
there is a formula where it says let me
tell you what the formula says the
formula that you may or may not have
memorize if you start at n is equal to 0
and if you go to infinity of a to the N
right in this case a is 1/2 that this is
going to be equal to 1 over 1 minus a so
your natural reaction would have been oh
ok well that sum that we saw that's
equal to the sum of n is equal to 0 to
infinity of 1/2 to the N which would be
equal to 1 over 1 minus 1/2
what's that 1 minus 1 that's 1 over 1/2
which would be equal to 2 and you'd be
like why God what did I do wrong there
right and I'll show you what you did
wrong this sum that you took the sum of
remember n is starting at 0 so this sum
that sums up to 2 is 1/2 to the nth 1/2
to the 0 is 1 plus 1/2 to the 1 one half
plus one half squared 1/4 plus 1/8 so on
and so forth right that is equal to 2
that is equal to 2 this problem and
that's why it was a little tricky this
problem they didn't want the Sun this
sum they wanted this sum 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8 plus so forth and so on
right so they wanted everything but this
one so if you subtracted this one from
both sides then you would say oh ok this
sum must be equal to 1 which is the
answer we got that way so that's why
sometimes you know memorizing formulas
this formula is a nice formula to
memorize it's very simple but it
sometimes becomes really confusing when
you're like oh boy but this is
when he starts at zero what happens when
n starts at one and to some degree I
really like this problem cuz it's
testing you to see if you really
understand what the formula is all about
anyway I'll see you in the next video